promise you're expecting their
privileges committee report to be
published later today will MP is going
to vote on the findings to actually
accept and accept the recommendations
from the committee well I can't
speculate obviously I haven't seen the
report yet but these are typically
matters for the house not the government
and it's the House of Commons and
Parliament that would decide the
appropriate course of action on a
personal level do you think Bryce
Johnson should be allowed to be an MP we
know that the report has found that he
misled Parliament uh you're talking
about a report that I haven't seen and
no one else has seen it wouldn't be
right to comment on it in advance of it
coming out and being published
um we've had enough about it boss
Johnson has stepped down because we know
what the report has said
if you're not willing to talk about it
now are you willing to do an interview
with us after the report comes up once
you had a chance to read it as you say
you're talking about a report that I
haven't seen no one has seen yet it
wouldn't be right to comment on it
before that's happened and these are
matters for the House of Commons and
Parliament will deal with them in the
normal way that it does